you
when we hear the term no true Dom as
opposed to notre-dame what we almost
automatically think of is the Cathedral
of Paris we simply call it notre Dom but
as I've already pointed out and we'll
see again and again and again there are
many cathedrals in France in fact most
of the ones we're going to look at in
detail dedicated to Our Lady that is to
say the Virgin Mary so we really
properly should say notre-dame de Pury
just as we should say no true Dom de
Chartres no true DOM the law or
notre-dame de Rance or whatever it might
be but nevertheless it's clearly
ingrained in our mind that no true Dom
first and foremost is a reference to
Paris now it's also obvious that no true
DOM means a lot of things other than a
12th century gothic cathedral we have
all kinds of images in our mind from
later times perhaps the most famous one
is from the book and then the great
movie The Hunchback of Notre Dom and we
have a picture here a still from an
early version of that movie and that's
sort of how we imagined Notre Dom the
Hunchback up in the tower with the
gargoyles and whatever and that's all
fine and dandy and legitimate after all
the Hunchback of Notre DOM is an
important novel and an important film we
however having said this we're going to
ignore all that and we're going to look
at Notre Dom in his 12th century context
but even in the 12th century when the
cathedral was built it was special and
let me suggest some reasons why first of
all obviously Paris is the capital of
France
now capital is a little bit later term
really but clearly it was a political
and administrative center of France and
became more so over the course of the
Middle Ages and so it is special in that
way it's marked as being special in that
way by the fact that if we look at Notre
Dom it is on an island in the send the
Ile de la Cite a and one of the things
that it shared on the island was the
space dedicated to the
palace of the King of France now today
only small parts of that Palace survive
and a thirteenth century royal chapel
survived Sant Chapelle which we'll look
at a little bit later on so obviously
this island in the 21st century looks
different than it did in the 12th or
13th it was dominated by the two great
figures the Bishop of Paris and the King
of France and they lived almost not
quite but almost across the street from
each other it's fair to say
metaphorically if not quite literally
that the Cathedral of Notre Dom was in
the shadow of the Royal Palace and vice
versa it's also clear because of that
that in some ways the history of France
and the history of the Cathedral of
Notre Dom are entwined in a way the
political history of France is entwined
with almost no other building except for
half for the Cathedral of Reims because
that's where the Kings were crowned it's
also important to say there's something
else special about Paris at the very
time that no true DOM was being built it
was the time of the flourishing of the
Cathedral School of Paris one of the
great intellectual centers of the 12th
century
it's a place for example where the great
philosopher Peter Abelard taught and in
fact by about 1,200 parts of that
Cathedral school had become kind of
quasi independent of the Cathedral moved
over to the left bank of the sin and
became the University of Paris the most
important university of the Middle Ages
so Paris was an extraordinarily
important intellectual center Thomas
Aquinas for example was the professor in
the 13th century at the University of
Paris and it's also worth mentioning
that Paris is extraordinarily important
in the history of music because the
music of the early Christian centuries
was monophonic everybody sang the same
notes at the same time ruger enchant it
was really more than any place else in
the cathedral of Paris that there were
experiments with Poli
music music people singing different
notes at the same time harmony and so
for many things intellectually and
musically and politically and
architectural e notre Dom is a very
important place